j'ai réveillé toute la France insoumise
ce week-end sont tous en colère il pense
qu'ils vont décider de qui j'invite ou
pas dans mon émission regardez Mathilde
panneau
personne n'a le droit de ne pas avoir
une pure un pluralisme dans les
expressions donc ce n'est pas monsieur
Hanouna qui décide qui vient ou non sur
son plateau ce n'est pas monsieur
son plateau
alors
il y a des gars ils vont venir ils vont
s'asseoir tranquille
génial bonsoir vous êtes excusez-moi je
ne connais pas vous êtes venus sur le
plateau je vais et en plus je l'aimais
bien ma petite panneau aussi elle a fait
plein d'émissions avec nous elle est
encore là et après un mois
Mathilde mais oui j'ai envie de qui je
veux Mathilde on n'est pas en période
d'élection j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
tableau à tenir sur les comptes c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs tous les comptes
qu'ils ont fait pendant les élections
sachez que voilà sur la chaîne C8 en
fait on doit tenir des comptes et tout
le monde doit parler le même temps tous
les partis mais quand on est hors
élection comme maintenant je peux
inviter tous les soirs un mec voilà je
peux inviter tous les soirs Fabien
Roussel tous les soirs il peut rester
là-bas sympa voilà donc Mathilde non tu
te trompes ma Mathilde si tu veux venir
en tout cas j'ai changé d'avis
vous pouvez tous venir mercredi je vous
invite voilà si veulent venir mercredi
que j'ai rien à faire mercredi je serai
là donc voilà donc vous venez si vous
voulez venir il y a pas de problème
après peut-être voilà je rechangerai
d'avis mais s'ils veulent venir mercredi
c'est avec grand plaisir bah oui soirée
de la gueule alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon
était devant sa téloche pour regarder
mathildeau la présidente du groupe LFI à
l'Assemblée sur BFM TV pour lui c'est de
la charmante après ces 8 le vola vénère
contre BFM TV voilà bon alors voilà il
est vénère il est vénère faut-il aller
sur BFM pour se faire insulter démolir
un terrain pour tout bout de champ donc
il était énervé sur cette tweet Jean-Luc
Mélenchon fait référence au simple
question des journalistes qui lui
demandent pourquoi tous les membres de
la France insoumise venaient dans TPMP
et si on était vraiment une émission
d'extrême droite selon eux un peu
contradictoire tout ça comme d'habitude
avec aussi les journalistes de BFM et
Benjamin Duhamel voilà je vous rappelle
Benjamin Duhamel c'était le fils du
patron de France Télévisions qui était
qui m'avait déjà j'avais pris en stage
je crois après il est parti avec
Marc-Olivier Fogiel sur BF plus que
Marc-Olivier Fogiel était très amis avec
Alain diamel bon voilà
donc voilà donc après voilà il a été
pistonné et c'est vrai que voilà bah ça
prouve bien que le piston c'est pas bon
il faut avoir le talon regardez vous
êtes présente le groupe la France
insoumise honnêtement on vous entend
depuis ce qui s'est passé sur le plateau
vous dites Cyril Hanouna encourage le
racisme et vous dites non non mais par
contre on peut continuer à y aller vous
comprenez que c'est une question
stratégique ce qui a étonné aussi en
partie il faut dire la vérité c'est que
vous le connaissez ce programme puisque
beaucoup de veau enfin beaucoup
plusieurs de vos députés ont été
chroniqueurs dans cette émission que
vous y rendez également régulièrement
donc vous aviez très bien enfin Louis
Boyard c'est très bien nous allons
partout où nous pouvons j'entends ce que
vous dites sur votre combat sur votre
volonté etc mais c'est la cohérence de
dénoncer un endroit avec beaucoup de
violence et de continuer à y aller alors
c'est pas fini Jean-Luc Mélenchon adore
Twitter en ce moment je sais pas ce qui
lui arrive ce matin la première chose à
laquelle il a pensé à lundi matin
tranquille tu vas tu prends un petit un
petit bol de Benco tout ça non mais
c'est vrai tu es tranquille tu prends
des chocapic tout ça donc il va tout ici
il veut saisir la recommande le saisir
leur conne ils ont pas que ça [ __ ]
mais sans déconner un truc maintenant tu
saisis la recommande mais arrêtez de
saisir alors il me propose voilà il
tient voilà après l'émission d'un
vendredi 100% à charge ils vont le reste
c'est vrai qu'après son sa vidéo on
aurait dû faire une émission hommage
nous saisissons une nouvelle fois la
recom y a-t-il une limite à la télé donc
alors on peut plus critiquer Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
était comme ça mais ouais mais c'est bon
alors Jean-Luc il est colère mais c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui
qui soit colère je vous ai montré plein
d'exemples vendredi et j'avais pas tout
mis parce que j'avais
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui parce que je voulais qu'ils kiffe
son week-end quand même
regardez comment il répond un
journaliste qui veut lui poser une
question dans une manif regardez j'ai
envie qu'il faut que ça va pas
alors abruti ça va qu'est-ce qu'il y a
on peut faire
encore
[Applaudissements]
donc apparemment Jean-Luc qui veut plus
aller sur C8 il peut aller sur BFM et on
verra plus non plus sur France Info
regardez comme il était hyper sympa avec
ce journal
alors il dit au gouvernement à
l'Assemblée nationale qui est le temple
de la démocratie il dit je ne reconnais
plus votre autorité au gouvernement
est-ce que c'est bien républicain comme
comportement
si vous si vous me demandez à moi est-ce
que vous prenez la désobéissance civile
ce que vous espérez c'est que Ruffin
ayant dit une chose moi je dise le
contraire et demain on peut savoir qui
buzz mais en chemin et ruffins à la
guerre
allez vous faire voir rognon il est
derrière la base c'est Mélenchon
donc voilà et donc voilà je vous l'avais
dit donc c'est vrai qu'il aime bien
s'embrouiller avec les journalistes avec
les Français dans la rue mais bon à
chaque fois je remets ça parce que
chaque fois qu'il se retrouve face à
Emmanuel Macron et ce qu'il a
parce qu'il a il va fouille et pas bien
et
[Rires]
monsieur Macron ce fut un festival feu
d'artifice de bobard même sur le
Président je suis très flatter parce que
il vit tellement ailleurs qui parle aux
gens comme à des domestiques moi je
parle jamais aux gens comme ça mais il y
en a comme ça on n'a pas toujours les
mêmes idées mais en tout cas c'est
toujours respectueux et c'est toujours
intéressant Macron premier qui nous fait
un discours qui sonne comme tout le
reste du décor de Versailles c'est du
carton pâtes c'est du faux marbre vous
avez dit que c'est le plus grand
xénophobe qu'on a évanuel Macron non non
vous pouvez pas le croire comment
faut-il parler d'abondance ça fait 5 ans
que cet homme a vidé les poches de tout
le monde
merci d'être venu chez nous ça m'a fait
plaisir ça m'a fait plaisir
au final notre relation mon Jean-Luc
d'ailleurs tu peux venir si tu veux
venir mercredi télévisions
mercredi ou bien si tu veux tu viens au
mercredi ou jeudi on va tu vois tu vois
quand tu peux venir moi je suis là je
bouge pas
je t'offrirai un petit godet moi
Jean-Luc et puis on va je suis sûr qu'on
va se retomber dans les bras ça se
connaisse ça c'est comme avec une ex et
tu la revois après tu es un si je
connaisse on va toujours s'embrasser
comme du comme du bon point
Jean-Luc grâce à toi les Français vont
plutôt pouvoir suivre sur C8 leur
nouvelle fiction
regardez
[Musique]
précédemment dans helfi de l'amour
Jean-Luc et Baba coulait des jours
heureux ensemble sur le même plateau
jusqu'au jour où Jean-Luc Junior est
venu rendre visite à tonton Baba chez
lui Nantes TPMP
après que Jean-Luc a fait une castadi en
dormant quelques jours d'affilée il se
réveilla pour tacler à la gorge papa
nous ne sommes pas vos copains et nous
ne le serons jamais
[Musique]
[Rires]
Jean-Luc va-t-il faire la paix avec Baba
vont-ils redevenir copain comme ralouf
verra ton prochainement Jean-Luc dans un
toc toc toc spécial et les filles
[Musique]
dans les filles de l'amour
on
t'attend Jean-Luc on t'attend